abiturientin wie wir 19 hat eine fahnen
lassen
ach so leon 11 ist in dieser familie der
familienspaß gute laune ist in die
wanten der tagesordnung
34 gg familienmenschen tauschen mit
fleischigen menschen leute mag sein ich
hab schon vor einigen tagen auch psycho
andreas im rahmen unserer serie tv
classics reagiert und heute haben wir
uns zwei bezaubernde youtube haken über
psyche andreas rausgesucht die wir
zusammen anschauen werden aber nicht nur
wir beide denn der legendäre mützen und
bartträger youtubes ist auch mit dabei
ich will aber nicht lange drum leute wir
ganz kurz mal die regeln erklären warum
muss seriös sein
immer gucken todes videos gucken dass
man sofort merkt man sich über das
verhalten des gesichts und was passiert
wenn man verliert einschnitt in die
ziehung ist ja als top-verlierer musste
ich halt einmal das messer hier in die
zunge stecken ok ja niemand erwartet das
was ich ihnen jetzt zeige
da hat
darf ich vorstellen 1 smartpad damit
können sie mir videos anschauen videos
anschauen videos anschauen muss alles
besser haben es noch sogenannte recht
wiegen so ist einfach nur so ein
trockenes und er hat nicht gleich zu ein
smart pad 1&1 dsl jetzt mit dem neuen 1
smartpad internet und telefon 99 einzige
auf neue internet- dennoch nicht mehr
scheiße aber wenn telefunken auch dabei
habt 99 dann wird sich was 99 jahren
er war mit telefon bleibt also wie hier
ist und er wird hier nicht dran london
egal ob du hier wird und nicht was ist
denn die ernsthaft dass ich wie so ein
wochenende war das wochenende okay aber
der zögert
aber sie bleibt auch ganz gut gegen
beschuss wir sehen dies nicht so
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
ok jetzt drei coolen den bauch kassiert
des gerätes reich endlich sommer 21 ort
schnell das gefühl die waffe ist also
zweidimensionale deswegen schießt mit
dem kopf arbeiten
ich will einfach nur ein team tour einen
verlust nicht zu heute alle verloren
ja ich weiß heute ein gefragter könnte
zum humor eigentlich nichts anfangen ich
weiß auch nicht warum ich das lustig
finden warum findet man ich bin 23 okay
ich sollte heimlicher seien nicht so was
richtig ist eine frage
das können sie mal bleibt aus aber wie
wird sich ändern wäre das wenn das
original aus ist das geil ist du weißt
immer wenn so bei youtube etwas
rückwärts läuft die wk 5 und komisch
genug da ausspruch so weiß
haben sie auch noch nicht machen genau
das würde ich auch gar nicht sein
ober zicke also irgendwas richtig darauf
an von der hochnäsigen zicke lasse ich
mir über auch nicht reinreden die kann
von morgens bis abends irgendwas
predigen ich habe mein standard bzw
ich habe mein standard beziehungsweise
unsere familie hat ein standard bzw
die hochnäsige ca
[Gelächter]
ich erwarte dass leute sagt man bitte
warum warum finde ich das lustig falls
ihr es nicht lustig findet noch mal
leicht sein das ist nicht lustig wie das
komponieren es nicht und es wird sich
hier im haushalt als werden
[Gelächter]
das ist so wie geil das wäre würde das
so bei den leuten einfach machst dann
bricht im krieg gestorben
also früher in der schuss hätte was
hatte der erste stunde klasse sind schon
klassenraum hierherkommt drei starben
was das youtube hat man eher so klar und
dann ist zwar weiß nicht in welcher form
sieht man schreien an
bei uns ist der laute ton nun gang und
gäbe bewegung gebe
[Gelächter]
man muss ja nicht so ein bullshit
zusammensetzen hallo wir gehen weiter
seine ex-freundin stilvoll ist das doch
schon das zweite youtube kacke dieser
heißt die andere hatte keinen titel die
hier heißt einfach youtube kacke
wasserbüffel sind
heißt doch ich will irgendwann kommt das
alter die wässer schon jetzt dass die
familie über aus leipzig haben sich ost
und west zu einer sexy wiedervereinigung
zusammengefunden
mutter sandra 22 ist ein besonders
erotisch ist ein exemplar an hier frau
schön einfach aber schön mit ihrem
augenbrauen verführt sie regelmäßig
nicht nur dem eigenen mann andreas 33
hat seine gedanken frühzeitig beendet
[Gelächter]
kennst du das wenn ein kind schon merkt
das ist eine ziemlich beschissene
genommen so einen sechsten sinn dafür
schon so richtig so warum so dass meine
eltern auch zur sexbombe erzogen
[Gelächter]
moment moment andreas 33 hat seine
gedanken frühzeitig beendet töchterchen
maria 4 wird so als sexbombe erzogen auf
das klassische familienmodell mutter
andrea 43 verbindet ihre energie nach
getaner arbeit als verkäuferin auf die
intensive pflege von heim und familie
für betonmischer matthias 42 heißt es
nach feierabend vor allem eines ihren
sie die pflege von der arbeit und danach
fliegt er noch die scheibe
daher ist auch wenn ich weiss nicht mehr
unterbrechen und wirtschaftstrends
[Gelächter]
abiturientin wie wir 19 hat einfallen
lassen so leon 11 ist in dieser familie
der familienspaß
gute laune ist in der tagesordnung
13 gg familienmenschen tauschen mit
fleischigen menschen der sich mit anders
und heute leute ist kein scheiß menschen
herzlich willkommen in unserem film
gemütlichen zuhause
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ich würde darauf gewartet dass sie
regieren das meer von der hochnäsigen
zicke lasse ich mir überhaupt nicht
reinreden ich habe mein standard bmw mit
viel gefühl mit ihrem co-star in dem
baggerbiss zeugen haben die schädigung
gutes gefühl
leute ich hoffe ihr könnt euch heute
dabei helfen dass wir das was wir heute
im job im studium in der schule oder
sonstwo gelernt habe wieder gut
vergessen konnte sich auf euer gehirn
ist jetzt wieder auf null gesetzt was
ihr jetzt unbedingt machen bis heute ist
ihr müsst den abonnieren -button
intensiv pflegen ok intensiv pflegen
ganz wichtig leute dann über die hälfte
von allen die diese videos sehen haben
den kanal nicht abonniert deswegen wenn
euch die videos gefallen lässt gerne mal
ein abo da und support hat nicht die
arbeiten sind der bestand verlinkt leute
hier drüben gibt es auch einfach ich
vorgeschlagen das video bis zum nächsten
mal pflegt eure scheiden